I want therapy to try to fix my fear of
flying and they and the therapist said
well
how when was the last time you flew I
said [__] Monday so you do it I said
yeah she goes well then you don't have a
problem you just don't like flying and
I'm like yeah I have a terrible fear of
flying she goes yeah a lot of people do
but if you can do it then that's then
you're there you're doing it yeah you're
figuring my thing with flying is I drink
uh I've had plane flights where I wasn't
drinking that where it's turbulence and
I dude I've I've sobbed crying no yeah
this sober October I had to fly to
Minneapolis doing the Target Center or
whatever and uh
and I mean and I can't drink and we're
taking the [__] red eye and it's
horrific turbulence and I'm In First
Class
49 years old crying my eyes out crying
my eyes out shaking holding on I I'm so
bad I will grab the person's leg next to
you I I'm I'm a horrible fear of I have
a fear of death really yeah okay it's
ultimately what it comes down to is I
have a terrible fear of death now has
this increased with success my fears
fear of death yes I understand that what
what is it I think it's like you get to
taste this life
that is oftentimes unimaginable and
you're like I don't I don't want to lose
this and not only that you have children
you have a wife like there's all this
life you get to live with them all these
things you get to see with them and you
and doing something frivolous doing
something dumb doing something like
[__] skydiving or whatever like that
the the reward of that is what you land
and you have an exhilarating moment the
risk is you throw away all this you've
worked for like I can completely
understand that yeah I have a I have a I
would say uh stuff you gotta get out of
here
oh yeah yeah I appreciate it yeah yeah
as soon as I saw you in here I was like
okay it's not happening again okay yeah
yeah yeah but he's still here no no it's
perfect he's still gonna remember that
you're uh yeah
but now you know there's no more cloudy
yeah yeah yeah okay go on that is crazy
that that is a but don't you that's
crazy that like that's crazy that that
actually happens to me that I don't have
control over it control over over when
the clown in the balloon showed up that
I shut down and I can't write my boat
for a little while
as crazy as that's a thing that I have
no control of yeah but that's the
phobias no but that's I don't know I
think that's the most entertaining thing
it's like do you have any phobias oh I
would definitely wouldn't say them out
loud now oh count what I said does homo
count
do I have any phobias yeah yeah I have a
huge fear of heights I do not [__] with
Heights
okay I'm claustrophobic and I have a
fear of heights I don't [__] with
Heights I got stuck on the train for
almost an hour once it was one of the
worst experiences of my life and now
anytime the train stops I freaked the
[__] out
I'll tell you what my claustrophobia is
so bad I have a hard time scuba diving
oh yeah
like like uh me and Rachel Ray were
supposed to go scuba diving with sharks
and they sent over the Rachel's
claustrophobic and they sent over the
the you have to have like a hood yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and I was like
I can't do that I would prefer to use
just the other yeah just auction have
you seen the guy who goes up they go up
uh in I forget who did it but he went up
in a U2 plane he went up in one of the
spy planes that goes out of the
atmosphere so they had to wear a helmet
like a space man's helmet and he said
they're they're watching him and he goes
okay my nose is itching
and so the guy goes just don't think
about it and he's like no but it's
itching really bad
yeah yeah yeah dude claustrophobia is a
[__] I didn't understand
claustrophobia and then I just got this
MRI recently on my shoulder [__] dude
yeah [__] I had one of those
all you had to do is your arm right no I
was rolled into the whole thing for you
yeah dude was an option dude I did just
the arm I I mine was my elbow was my
shoulders my elbow yeah so I had to put
my arm in there for like I want to say
like 30 minutes or 45 minutes I was in
there forever and I and I
Panic would hit me and I could feel it
well up like going here we go we're
gonna have a panic attack right now and
then I'd go and I took a Xanax before I
went and it still didn't [__] help oh
man explain to me so the MRI machine is
just on your you can do whatever you
want over here you have to put your arm
in but they tell you you can't move it's
the not moving thing that's the problem
yeah if I had my arm in some machine and
I could kind of like roll around and do
whatever I'd be okay but when I was
rolling no no you had to stay still to
stay still that's [__] crazy I'm back
like this I'm in this little tube and I
can't and I can't get a full breath and
I'm sure there's a function of
claustrophobia but I can't get a full
breath and I feel like oh if I could
move a little bit I could get one but
I'm breathing it like it feels like 80
of a full breath so now I'm in this
little Panic where I'm like well how do
I get that last [__] 20 am I gonna
pass out in here I had to tap out
halfway through I had to tap out go back
in to finish it I literally think I'm
gonna my my logical brain and riding the
train still gets stuck for four or five
minutes my logical brain's like nothing
is gonna happen you and and I'm like no
no I'm gonna run out of oxygen I told my
wife on like our third date if we ever
got stuck in an elevator for 30 seconds
you would never respect me again dude
you would never respect me again it
would be the most embarrassing thing if
you guess you got stuck on a train to
him one time she put her hand on my
chest just like calm me down she said
your heart was [__] pounding dude I
got stuck in an elevator with a bunch of
Japanese men
if you think Panic sounds bad in English
panic in Japanese is like [__]
kicking cats like it was and I and I was
like and they started freaking out and
then it's making me worse and I opened
the doors to the elevator opened the
doors to the elevator and open the other
doors and climbed out the most I was
like I would 100 try to do that I
wouldn't be strong enough I'd fall to
the bottom but I would try let's let's
go panic for panic I was in a uh Top
Thrill drag or Drop Top Fuel dragster
right Top Fuel dragster it's a drag race
so they put you in I'm riding just a
passenger first of all you're in a in a
flame retardant suit zip up right put
the helmet on gloves on they put you in
they five point harness you and then
they then they strap your hands to your
neck
so that you can't because you're gonna
reach out and grab something I don't
want you to touch anything so your hands
are here I'm not doing that so they put
me on all the stuff and then they go all
right we'll get back to you I go hold on
up I need out of here and they're like
well he's gonna be here in a second I go
no no I need out of here right now I'll
tell you panic for panic this is the
worst this is the worst
foreign
if you know the answer it's a game show
on roller coasters the roller coaster
they put us in is out of Magic Mountain
in La it's the one where you stand up
they harness you in and then they they
push
like you so you fly through it they have
a vest on me for to hold a camera a go
GoPro Mount and I might so I'm and I'm
and I'm like really tied into this thing
we pull into the station where the
second where like one car out and we're
sitting there in this and someone goes
wonder what's going on and they're like
uh all right we're having a little
problem we're gonna bring in in a second
they bring us in
the floor raises and they go all right
uh we're having a problem with the
releases it shouldn't be a big deal so
we have to wait until the guy the head
mechanic's gonna come out and he'll fix
it he'll be here shortly and I said
excuse me can you just undo mine and
they said no we need to do them all the
same time I said yeah but I'm having a
little bit of a panic attack and so the
lady who's running it comes over and
goes it's it's gonna be okay you're the
safest place you can be but he's on his
way I said where is he at the park she
goes uh he's in his home in Tarzana no
oh boy [__] way it's five o'clock
[__] me I was in this thing for 45
[__] minutes in this thing no like
this facing down
I mean melting down the woman the poor
woman had to sit
underneath me and hold my hand because
and I was I was crying
I'm the host of the show I'm a [__]
the host of the show and I'm freaking
out I don't want to die you [__] can
someone call me if you sing me a song or
something that might distract me I'm
[__] yeah I've had so many you wanna
you know what's even worse than that
have you ever been stuck you're making
me feel bad we've been stuck in deep
snow no shall we go we go we go hella
skiing in Switzerland we go up to like
[__] 10 000 feet 12 000 feet whatever
the [__] it is airs then I'm hungover
we're all in snowboards and they put
beacons on our chests like what's the
beacon for he goes it's better to locate
the body I said what just locate the bat
in my sanding right say you fall into a
krabass I can find your body right I
said that right right I'm like oh God
find my body what do you mean find your
body and he goes it's for us it's not
for you don't worry don't worry it's for
you and I'm going hold on there's a
chance I'll disappear and he's like oh
yes okay so just stay real close to me
because I don't go and grab us and he
was all right let's go and we start
going now it's it's it we're on on the
top of a mountain in Switzerland so it's
it's what I would only guess maybe
four feet of powder I mean it's just
powder everywhere so we start going and
I realize I'm a good snowboarder but I
hadn't snowboarded in a while and you
know your first run you're always like
oh yeah I'm warming up a little bit it
was my first run this is my first run in
a couple years and I'm on top of a
mountain in Switzerland and
all of a sudden I catch a toe and I go
Face Forward into the snow and I
disappear I take my arms to push up oh
and there's nothing there there's
nothing there like it's too deep and I'm
like panicking going oh my God this is
what they mean yeah to find the body I
literally go I'm gonna die here I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die and I'm [__]
sitting there for I'm not even joking 10
minutes upside down in snow trying to
push and all of a sudden he'll feel a
hand grab my back pull me up and he goes
you should see your sound guy my sound
guy is upside down now skis like this
and gear everywhere and I was like get
us the [__] off this mountain it was
dude getting stuck in snow is [__]
terrifying I could go this is I could
talk anxiety and Terrors for hours
sinkhole scares the [__] out of me dude
I grew up in [__] Florida sinkholes
were everywhere yeah you'd be playing
football on the street one day next day
sinkhole I swear to God I was thinking
about this last night you know when the
ground just swallows up a house or
whatever what what happens to the guy
I'm I'm like if that happened to me
that's just how I die that's how you
don't get them out
it's like being buried alive it's the
worst thing that could possibly have you
ever seen there's a clip there's a clip
online I saw one time I haven't been
able to find since of a guy in England
explaining quicksand at the beach and he
goes he goes I'm bad with accents but he
goes he goes uh okay this is how I don't
know what action I'm doing that's the
Switzerland guy yeah Switzerland yeah
hello all right all right so this is
quicksand they're very normal now I have
a safety gears everywhere everyone's
here we've got a compressor air
compressor to get me out so but I want
to show you how it works it's very
simple you stand here and in a matter of
seconds you'll feel your ankles sick in
now if you struggle like such it goes a
little deeper I know it's safe for me to
get up to my knee we won't go much
deeper than my knee but watch this as I
try to get out I'm now my knee so that's
how it works let's let's get me out now
and someone goes okay
and he just keeps sinking and they're
like
hold on okay this is not funny anymore
let's let's get me out now and he starts
going deeper and deeper and you're
watching this guy [__] yeah
this is a video you can find it online I
can't watch it again how about this have
you ever seen the guys the guys who go
spelunking
dude dude we went spelunking in New
Zealand why
can you explain real quick it's caving
yeah it's caving no no there's a
combination of the splunking we did was
in water and as this is the scariest
[__] thing as we enter it they they
go all right we need you to get through
the birth canal and I said what's that
and they go it's this canal it gets us
into the cave it's a little tight so uh
but just get on your stomach and you'll
Marine crawl through and you'll there's
just enough room for you to breathe but
there's one part where your face is
going to go on Earth just keep going
forward it opens up uh nope and so we
get into the birthing Canal climb
through and we spend the next hour and a
half in the most terrifying experiences
I've ever had in my life at one point
they would there was a waterfall and in
order to get you had to get up the
waterfall and they'd take you you can't
hear anything it's a waterfall they put
you behind the waterfall so you're
behind the waterfall and then you had to
climb up from behind it but at one point
you were just getting [__]
and then as you got to the top they
grabbed you and they put you in a room
where it was this tall the water was to
here and we were all sitting here just
breathing like this
now the only thing this is crazy the
only thing that would calm me down and I
don't know the explanation was a camera
on me if I knew a camera was on me I
could almost act yeah like and I would
so I'd keep going put the camera fear of
being embarrassed is worse than your
fear of claustrophobia and we got done
that that [__] thing in New Zealand
and I remember getting out and all of us
were like we're [__] alive they have
in in Colorado there's a there's I mean
horrible stories of these guys who go
into these caves there's I think it's
called caverns of the wind and they're
caves and they go in and they will get
in and they'll get stuck like this and
they'll get their Little Rock chiseler
to try to open up space for them I mean
I've Googled it and watched it it is
the crazy thing is sometimes you're
spelunking and then torrential rain
comes that's what happened with those
Thai boys the Thai kids yeah and the
rain raises the water level so now those
parts that you had to crawl through are
completely underwater yeah so those
tight little spaces that's why they had
to give them like the oxygen tanks and
[__] to get out but that why why were
they doing that it was a common thing to
do to go in like very normal to go into
that cave and go to this place where I
think you go to a beach I watched the
document a lot I think there's some cool
beautiful like all those stalactors like
crystals it is yeah it is worth the
reward for me but yeah it's it's I've
done a lot of spelunking I did one I did
one in Austin uh and uh the guy they go
all right we're going to lower you in
they have a pothole like a like a like a
like just like you see on the street and
the guy takes the top off and it is just
the width of my shoulders and he says
and they put a harness on you and he
goes all right I'm gonna lower you down
but you're too big you need to go one
arm down one arm up to get through and
so they lower me down I am [__] all
I'm thinking is I have a GoPro on like a
chesco pro that's up in my face and all
I'm thinking is I'm rescuing Baby
Jessica that's all I I was thinking like
maybe yes it was a story from the 80s of
a girl who fell down a well like a young
girl and the nation was captivated by it
and so and then but then he yells up hey
you're gonna see an area where it seems
like you should get out do not get out
and I'm like what the like
all of a sudden it opens up to this
beautiful place now you're so [__]
claustrophobic that the second you see
that my he's right my initial thought
was I should stop here and take a breath
before I have to go down I think it was
like 180 feet I think was the what they
lowered you down and I and as I see this
this Oasis I go [__] this I'm gonna keep
going and and you go into even a smaller
cave and you're just getting lowered and
then it opens up to huge [__] cave
and you're like and all I'm thinking is
I gotta get the [__] out of here that
way I mean then you walk out right isn't
there another exit
yeah have you done this no but I've seen
this before and it's like why are we
going this way yeah let me go there's
like a regular accident yeah
spelunking's pretty badass you know bro
have you seen the uh they're these like
natural water slides sometimes and
sometimes they're usually part of like
rivers or like waterfalls now Duvall was
that one and what you do is you go
through this hole in the Rock and then
you're completely kind of like submerged
with the flowing water and then you pop
out so you got to hold your breath for a
couple seconds
something happened where like Duvall
went through the wrong entrance in the
Rock and got stuck couldn't breathe
can't see
in the middle of this and the water's
churning everywhere right oh I got the
crazy story for you afterwards water's
churning everywhere kicks pushes finally
gets put back into the funnel and then
gets but he's like dude I thought I was
gonna die like I was like making my
piece in that moment crazier story
there's this wave pool that they're
building I won't say who it is and a
very famous
um UFC fighter UFC fighter right
is going to check out this wave pool The
Wave Pool isn't ready yet now the way
the wave pools work is there these
engines right at the bottom of the pool
suck in all the water from the pool
shoot it back out that's what creates
the waves right
he's waiting to go surf
the engines didn't have grates on them
now all wave pools have grates
the engines suck in the water he gets
sucked into the engine room with the
water
okay
it's not like he gets spit back out with
the water for minutes he's getting
smashed around for whatever they shoot
out the water he can breathe for a
second it's pitch black he doesn't know
what's going on right then the water
comes sucked back in shoots out five
minutes like they shut down the pool but
they're like where the [__] is he how do
we get him out think about that you're
just in this thing you could breathe for
a second and then nothing breathe for a
second nothing no way out terrifying how
do you get out how do you get out they
stopped the pool
uh we'll bleep it
[Laughter]
shut the [__] up